yeah I got a special mandalorian coin I
got one from John okay well good for you
yeah so do you ever watch do you have a
special John did not give me a coin
what are you Michelle exactly no we
don't see your face yet
just get me a star-studded role I want
to talk about your tweet first of all
what the guy that's running oh man I was
like you know when you're on set and you
you know you just start restlessly kind
of like looking at your phone or
whatever and I saw that somebody sent me
that link and I thought it was hilarious
just like I loled
and so I reposted it that's the react
play of my story as always what
twitter.com people have the hots for the
mandalorian with or without seeing a
space I mean it's like you're making
that up please somebody's checking the
head no off-camera okay fine I believe
you all right cool that's twisted I know
everybody likes a uniform like to the
extreme I guess I gotta ask you the
question that I know you're not gonna
answer but are you gonna take that
helmet do you want to know I think I do
I feel like if I don't ask I'm not doing
my job right I got you I got you
and if I tell you I'm not doing mine but
does anyone ever take off their masks
secretly boba fett am i secretly Boba
Fett these are all really good questions
yeah yeah yeah I know and you're already
working on season two right now we are
working on season two we were working on
season two today we'll be working on
season two tomorrow
[Music]